en parlant c'est fort parce que nous on
sera évidemment dans le secteur visiteur
au sénat mais voilà j'espère bien qu'à
un moment donné ils devront lever la
tête pour me regarder pour dire oui on
fait partie de ceux qui ont qui n'ont
pas voté pour vous et le problème sera
toujours là dans six mois on nous aurons
peut-être un gréviste de la faim
peut-être un deux trois quatre en france
et c'est pas normal
oui je veux voir c'est dans le milieu
ces personnes qui n'ont pas voulu passer
à autre chose et essayer une loi de
droite c'est parce qu'on part les
entreprises et ben non ça n'a pas
fonctionné on a mis on préfère mettre le
problème sur un mouchoir que de 2,2
voilà c'est une loi de droite on parle
d'entreprises
dont la droite rue c'est ça et c'est
incompréhensible et il le voilà c'est
arrêter d'avoir peur arrêtez d'avoir
peur il n'y a personne alors à la place
de ces gamins il n'y a personne on fait
quoi on ferme les entreprises les
petites entre les découpes tite
entreprises comme la mienne si on n'a
pas ces personnes là on faire le choix
n'est là parce qu'on ne peut plus
travailler et les plaquistes les
mécaniciens c'est la même chose
[Musique]